f is a linear function whose table of
values is shown below and they give us
three different x values and the
corresponding f of x values
which graphs show functions that are
increasing faster than f so when we're
talking about increasing faster we're
really talking about a higher rate of
change of y with respect to f or a
higher rate of change of the vertical
axis with respect to the horizontal axis
which is another way of saying is which
of these have a higher
have a steeper slope than the function f
so let's see what the change in our
vertical axis is with respect to our
change in our horizontal axis once again
the greek letter
this
triangle is the greek letter delta which
is shorthand for change in so this is
the change in f over the change in x
so we see over here when x changes by
one when x changes by one our the value
of our function changes by positive 5.
changes by positive 5. and it's linear
so that's true of any between any two
between any two points the ratio between
our change in f and our change in x is
the same if we go up one again
we have plus one in the in the x
direction we are once again increasing
by five if you start from this point and
go all the way here so if you go plus
two
if you go plus two along x you're gonna
go plus 10
plus 10 along f so it would be 10 over 2
which is still 5. so either way the
slope or the rate of change of the
vertical axis with respect to the
horizontal axis is 5 for f now let's see
which of these increase faster
well a definitely a isn't even
increasing so we can a is decreasing as
x increases y is decreasing so this
can't even be that definitely can't be
the case
if we look at this one right over here
it looks like
it looks like let's see if we start over
here if we increase one it looks in
along the x direction if our change in x
is one it looks like our change in y is
exactly five one two three
four
five so it looks like for choice b
for choice b our slope is exactly five
or change in y over change in x is
exactly five so it's not increasing
faster than f it's increasing the same
as f
now let's look at c
and so i'm going to try to find a point
where it looks like i
i have kind of an integer point right
over here so that's the point negative 3
comma negative 3 and if i move 1 in the
x direction
it looks like i'm increasing by more
than five i'm increasing one two three
four
five six
seven
eight it looks like it looks like so
this one looks like it has a slope of
eight so this one does this one is
increasing faster than f so we'll circle
that right over there and now let's look
at this choice so if we start right over
here and i just picked this point
because that's a nice integer coordinate
it's at the point 2 comma negative 4.
if we increase by 1 if we increase by 1
if we increase x by 1 then we increase y
by 1 2
3 looks like about three and a half
definitely not five in order for it to
increase as fast as f it would have to
increase by five so it would have to be
up here so it would have to one two
three four five it would have had to be
up here the line would have had to look
something more like would have looked
something more like that just to match f
much less grow faster than f so d does
not meet the criteria it is only c